vouloir ajouter la carotte dans un bar
il est bourré de mecs ils rentrent dans
le bar ne peut plus et regarde tous les
mecs du marais les écouter tous ceux qui
sont à gauche c'est des connards et tous
ceux qui sont à droite cds merde
il ya un mec très bien moi je suis pas
une mère et la remet toi gauche
[Applaudissements]
très très chic et un homme bouscule une
dame ou comme ça du mois dorment je suis
désolé mais si votre coeur est aussi
doux que votre poitrine
vous allez me pardonner non et la femme
les souris à lui dit vous êtes à moitié
pardonnée
si votre coude est aussi dur que votre
que je suis chambre d'où nous vient du
japon en rouge grady les petits
chaperons rouges il cependant rien très
gros succès sur les réseaux sociaux à la
la la la la
alors il va proches et voit dans un
étang un leloup sublime blonde c'est
rare les houblons al houblon un houblon
fête de la bière avec il voit sa voie
celle qui est en train de se noyer parce
qu'il est pris dans les années phares
elle nous fait alors dans l'eau il va
dans l'eau elle prend le le p'tit loup
par la tire comme ça jusqu'à la rive
et là il se pense pas mon prince
charmant mais beau alors me mo
elle était donnée la petite mais qu'est
ce que c'est je vais vous raconter
mademoiselle issue il se trouve que
j'étais maudit par une méchante fée qui
m'a dit tu ne seras sauvé que c'est
honteux soupe
vous m'avez sauvé je suis sauvé mais
vous pouvez me lâcher là que maintenant
[Applaudissements]
j'ai répondu à l'eau qui est là je sais
pas du tout qui s'est alors pas passer
mon fils aîné et lyon c'est mon bébé
renchérit tac blague m'a dit à moi que
ça débouche sur une passe pour bouder
patois vouloir quoi basez vous je
t'écoute mon chéri claude simard il a
dit quoi
tant qu'il troquera ses membres alors
vas-y vidéo alors dis-moi qui savent pas
quoi avait entendu tu es sûr que c'est
une bonne idée pourquoi pas déçu c'était
face à maxime je te bats la bagarre toi
je sais pas dit moi bah longueur
je t'embrasse chérie je t'aime motivator
l'histoire d'un c'est un jeu vif qui est
au bord de la faillite
c'est juste comme intangible est atterré
qu'on vide pendant qu'elle vous rendez
vous un énorme rendez vous sur les
champs elysées qui peut pas rater parce
que il peut décrocher un investisseur
qui est pas loin de mettre 10 millions
d'euros dans cette start up et donkey ça
fait des semaines qu'il attend ce rendez
vous s'est il est à l'agonie
donc il convient il faut se garer et il
a rendez-vous le mec lui a dit à 10
heures pile
donc le mec cherche une place il est
21h55 21h57 9h58 mais que dit mon dieu
et dis voilà ça fait longtemps que je
prie plus mais il gît là il faut
vraiment m'aider mon dieu lady vraiment
il faut ce rendez vous il faut que j'aie
cet argent et gmail à dieu si tu me
trouves une place s'il ya un mec qui me
laisse une plage t'en supplie je te jure
je suis un million de donation à la
synagogue je vais faire tous les chats
bad je vais donner à tous les gens à qui
je peux donner je vais t'aider du mieux
que je peux mais je t'en supplie aide
moi à ce moment là il ya une voiture
juste devant lui qui déboîte fait ça va
te dérange pas que j'ai compris
[Applaudissements]
quitterie religieux il en afrique qui se
baladent il fait son safari et un moment
donné tu tombes sur un sable mouvant et
tombe la salsa bleus mouvaux mais bon le
principe du samedi 20 décembre bien sûr
et plus il descend puis dit mon dieu
sauve moi mon dieu sur moi tailler un
pompier par hasard qui passent par là
j'ai pas besoin de votre aide
mode jeu et va m'aider il étonné moi
vous n'êtes pas un imam odieux et va
m'aider le pompier par l'oti continué à
descendre mon dieu s'il vous plaît
aidez-moi aidez-moi le popir vient
écouter monsieur sabine et là allait
mourir
evans orange et même sauvé le pompier
s'en vont encore hélas il descend il est
là le mec le monde tient son mémoire
mauguin son mémoire le pompier revient
dit donne moi ta main je vais trouver
dit normand budget va sauver va me
sauver le mec qui meurt quand même quand
elles arrivent là haut il dit mon dieu
vous m'avez abandonné et je t'ai envoyé
trois fois les pompiers
[Applaudissements]
c'est un monsieur tous les ans enfin
tous les ans tous les jours et promène
sa vache loin de son village mais très
loin de son village et ce jour là il a
promène plus loin que d'habitude et
maintenant la nuit va tomber il sait pas
comment rentrer avec sa vache et à
personne c'est les routes de campagne il
ya de l'herbe à dreux ac l'herbe la
gauche et une grande route
la personne qui peut l'aider et d'un
coup ce milieu de la route
il entend un gros vacarme mais un bruit
de moteur de malades est en fait c'est
une belle ferrari qui arrivent et qui se
pointent juste devant lui et l'autriche
et au manga au manga arrête-toi d'autres
et s'arrêtent pour tresser l'iran qu'il
sorte à voiture effet qu'est ce que tu
fais élective âge là tu peux bouger te
plait je suis en retard mois écoute ma
femme attend pour le souper tu peut
m'accompagner d'accord même si la
meilleure volonté du monde je
t'accompagne métrage la muse te plaît
allez aide moi à stopper mi juillet à mi
août à vache c'est pas ta ferrari est
une boule derrière il s'est fait avoir
le même où devait de caravanes il fait
bel et bien la tâche et on y va
ok d'accord ils l'attachent il se met à
côté et le mec il commença à rouler en
ferrari je sais pas en première on fiche
est pas moins 50 100 km/heure et
commence à tracer comme ça et le petit
vieux est là et tout ça il fait écoute
tu peux pas aller plus vite ma femme
attend je sais pas moi c'est pour ta
vacheret lemay qui retrace sur le rétro
la vache a fait ça il faut être subir la
vache en effet mais va plus vite ma
femme attend pour le souper et vas-y va
plus vite hissé en deuxième et tout ça
maintenant ferrari 120 kilomètres/heure
main et comment ça roule très vite et la
vache il la regarde dans le rétro à fait
ça
suis bien bref et loteries le charrie le
chari mais pas une fois plus vite ma
femme écoute c'est pour ta vaches moi je
m'en fous moi je peux aller très vite
mais c'est pour ta rage va plus vite mon
aller 3è allez on y va
180 km/heure - et commence à tracer la
vache
un moment donné et l'autre tellement et
le show fait c'est quoi tu m'emmerdes
avec ta va chez moi je la trouve et
abbas il va rester un fil alors il
commence 5e 6e à et maintenant il fait
du 300 km/heure et n'osent même pas voir
dans le rétro comment elle va la vache
et un moment donné ils regardent de
l'oeil de le rétro un peu la vache et la
vache est faite à la maman donner la
balle je fais ça tu as aiea va crever
mais non elle met le clignotant à va
doubler
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]